hey everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today we are doing another
q a
for november i stumble over that every
single time
because every single time i don't even
know what month it is anymore this video
is sponsored by keeps we will hear more
from them
somewhere in the middle but for now to
the questions so there is one question
that i got asked more than any other
question which i guess i should have
anticipated but somehow stupidly did not
so i will just answer it from the jump
and put it in the headline
with the idea of if you wanted your
answer to this question it is here you
don't have to stay for the rest of the
video you do you mostly just people
being like what are you doing next and
when can we find out
um because for anyone who missed it i
did announce last week that i
am leaving rooster teeth meaning leaving
fun house and inside gaming
where i have been working for about two
and a half years now i did say this in
my video and
and you know sort of vaguely on social
media um but i'm not allowed to say
where i'm going yet or what i'm doing
yet i know that sometimes people think
that people hold off on announcing
things for like
dramatic effect or something but that's
certainly not the case for me this is
just something that the company i'm
going to be working with
has asked me to do so i will be able to
tell you guys what i'm doing next
in i think i had most recently said two
to three weeks but now it's more like
two weeks
the date could change i'm not 100
positive so i don't want to lock that in
but um i can tell you what i'm doing
next
soon i don't want to give any hints i
don't really want to allude to anything
the only thing that i will say
is um so many people have been like oh
i bet she's going to go be a community
manager or some kind of like social
media director
and i just on that one just because it's
so common
i want to be like i would rather die
than work in social media professionally
zero interest in ever doing that so for
that one just specifically
just to be very clear have never
expressed interest in it
can't imagine much worse
full respect to the people who do that
job but yeah otherwise i'm still really
excited to tell everyone what i'm doing
i'm not withholding it for any personal
reasons it is like i've been
professionally asked of me
um but i will tell you all literally as
soon as i can i sadly can't say anything
else
i'm sure i'll post a tweet and uh post a
video here when i'm allowed to announce
it um more thoroughly
so yeah sorry i can't give it away now
but should be very soon geralt stark
said
it's funny that this person with this
username asked this question which game
is the best narrative design other than
the winter three and what are some
skills to develop for a game designer
other than level design
um i can't speak to that as someone who
is not a game designer i'm sure there
are much better resources than asking
me uh who has not worked in game design
um but first game that comes to my head
when thinking about narrative design
is uh near automata um i think that game
is
is a feat in storytelling in a very
unique way
uh but i also actually really do think
the last of his part two is
um in a way that like i don't even
like talking about this game anymore
because people get so heated about it
but
i really respect what the last of his
part two did and i say that as someone
who did not love that game but what that
game did
was give you a story that is very
grueling
um and and negative in a lot of ways and
then
i think intentionally drag on so that
while you were playing as characters who
were
experiencing very negative emotions you
were also experiencing those negative
emotions things felt arduous
things felt like they took too long um
and i think that that is
a very interesting narrative design
choice that i really do respect
my bigger issue with it is that while i
understand
the point and again respect it um it
ultimately didn't make it more fun for
me to play
i mean fun such a reductive web but it
didn't make it a better player
experience for me personally
um i just got the point uh so i think
that that is a very interesting
uh approach to narrative design for sure
and i like i said i really do respect
what they did there i think it's very
unique
in that way one of my go-to's
potentially not narrative design i guess
you could argue it's more writing than
narrative design specifically in this
case but i always say spec ops the line
i think spark ops align does a very uh
good job of presenting you a story and
making a very strong point and of course
having a political stance that it
doesn't beat you over the head with i
mean it does
but it doesn't just say the words at you
it just shows you the point that it's
making in a way that i think is very
smart
so those would be the three that come to
mind jordan jones asked do you believe
your college education was worth it
what effect has it had on your career
today um
yes and no so for anyone that doesn't
know i studied a bachelor of mass
communication majoring in journalism and
entertainment
and there are certainly lessons that i
learned that don't necessarily apply to
hobbyist
journalism or reporting which is what i
would consider games media to be it's
not quite
the same as um general news reporting or
even court reporting which i have done a
little bit of as well
i do think that uh studying made me a
better
editor and i do do a lot of editing it
made me better at
knowing how to structure features and
stuff to cut out um the unimportant
information
how to source things correctly um i
think that it made me
me better for sure do i think it is
required to get into the field
ultimately no and i think that's an
issue with games journalism
however the stuff that i think helped me
the most was the stuff that that has
um skills that i picked up that i have
used in my career now that i might not
have
um used just specifically in journalism
things like marketing
are always really helpful to me because
i am able to
see something that is marketing and look
through it quite efficiently because i
like i studied marketing i know how
manipulative that practice is intended
to be and i know some of the tricks from
doing a year of
studying marketing doesn't mean that i
could
do marketing well but it means i can
recognize marketing tactics which i
think definitely helps me as a
journalist but also just broader stuff
that helps like at a company like
rooster teeth like i did screenwriting
i did take a video game course i did
audio design
stuff that has given me just like a very
broad skill set that um i
wouldn't have had otherwise so i
definitely appreciate it for that we
interrupt this broadcast to read
the sponsored part of this video
seriously though did you know that two
out of three guys will experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left with keeps treatments uh
usually take between four to six months
to see results so it's important
to act fast the sooner you start using
it the more how you'll save
is pretty much the gist and you don't
even have to worry about going to the
doctors well you used to have to go to
the doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription
but now thanks to keeps you just visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered
right to your home they make it easy and
deliver your medication every three
months so you can say goodbye
to pharmacy checkout lines and being
around other humans in general
keeps also offers generic versions of
the only two fda approved hair loss
products out there
so find out why keeps has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
why over 100 000 men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com alana
pierce or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that's k e
e p s dot com slash
alana pierce i don't know how to do my
own name in that voice gregory inman
because it's very related asked
what's the chalky milk looking drink you
are always drinking with the froth it
always looks so delicious
this is a latte shout out to my
nespresso machine really saved my life
this year i tell you
sly spread said being and games
journalist influenza
i don't identify as either of those
things are you unable to hate on a
company like epic because you need to
keep neutral
uh no i don't think that there is any
requirement for anyone
in journalism or the influencer space to
keep neutral on anything when you are
reviewing something of course you should
attempt to
but uh i think it is probably more
healthy if everyone just has biases and
acknowledges their biases and i don't
mean that in a negative way so what i
probably mean to say
is more preferences reality is every
single human alive
is biased um everyone has preferences
they have things they like and dislike i
think that you are a better
reporter or influencer or commentator
or whatever you want to call it if you
don't try to pretend you don't
because you do that's the way that
humans work we are incapable of
objectivity and instead you just tell
people what your biases are
so for example cyberpunk every time that
i've ever spoken about cyberpunk i was
like
super biased about this game i'm very
excited about it i i haven't been this
excited about a game in ages
and that is separate from my involvement
in it and then obviously when that
it was a thing that i was able to
announce i was just like i'm very
excited about this game also i'm in this
game
my biases are on the line it is up to
you if you want to listen to what i have
to say or not
knowing how i feel about the game does
it mean that i am unable to
openly love cyberpunk no i think that
that's silly um and there are
companies that i have hated on um
frankly while i was at ign i think i
made some of the harshest content we
were making at the time
against publishers um and in some cases
developers i certainly feel like i was
doing that
specifically where ea is concerned i'm
also just very anti-micro transaction in
stance and i've always been very public
about that
um so ultimately my answer is no there
is no requirement for me to keep neutral
i can hate on whatever company i want to
hate on i think i'm just generally a
pretty rational person and don't buy
into like the youtube angry man
[ __ ] i don't know what else to call it
but [ __ ] i'm like [ __ ] this company i'm
like
i just don't have that in me ultimately
answer is no and we should stop telling
people not to be biased we should just
ask them to own their biases
and note accidental goat said if you had
one day to do whatever you wanted
completely free of any responsibility
and with no restrictions what would you
do
i would go to space my number one life
goal has always been to go to the
international space station
um i can't see any way that that happens
really unless i somehow get filthy rich
uh which also seems unlikely to me but
that's the goal
i'd love to go nicholas bloom said found
out recently you can sing
[Laughter]
now that you hopefully have more spare
time you're going to start putting up
song covers
um one i've been meaning to do it for a
little bit anyway
but like the reason that i wanted to
read this comment specifically is that
i will have less spare time not more
spare time i don't know where you're
getting the idea that i will have more
spare time
oh this is very relevant to what i said
before tim tim s said can you explain
why the secrecy are a new job
why can't you tell before a certain date
is it a state secret seems like a lot of
youtubers not you say
i've got big news but can't say anything
yet just for hype um
they've asked me not to that is how
these companies work because they want
to control their own pr
so it was the same with rooster teeth
they were very specific about
how we were announcing it and when
because they want to control the
announcement because they're the company
rather than just letting me announce it
and run with it
when they don't expect it whenever i
want to so it is up to them
um is just the answer jonathan hamlin
said hi elan i've been following you
since i janna this is my first comment
welcome hope everything is going well
for you yeah
no i actually am doing okay all things
considered this year i just missed my
family mostly but thank you i hope it's
well for you too
my question is kind of dumb but that's
where my brain is now what top five
games other than cyberpunk are you
looking forward to playing the most on
next-gen
i do feel like i've spoken about this
stuff a few times um
just in like live streams and stuff but
uh
right now the games i'm most excited
about would be number one my absolute
number one is death loop i love arcane
so much
um i love that kind of game uh and i
also just really like the style of it so
death loop is number one that's
obviously bethesda published
ps5 exclusive but i think
we'll probably come to the xbox at a
later date as well unclear on that
um but that is the one that i'm super
excited about i'm also really excited
about ratchet and clank
that was for tech reasons for the same
reason is actually the medium which i
think is out december
10th um because i think the way that
those games have that like world
swapping thing
um it seems like it it actually is more
accurate in the medium than it is
in ratchet when we saw more gameplay i
was starting to think that maybe it
didn't work the way that i thought it
did but it's it's about load times
effectively and how they are
simultaneously potentially running
multiple worlds um so i'm excited for
those games not from a player's
perspective but from like
an industry fan perspective um to see
how they
run and function for sure definitely
interested and avowed because of the
studio and because i love me a fantasy
rpg
um same reason for fable like i don't
know what that game's gonna be
i only really love the first fable i
don't care very much about two and three
um fable anniversary or fable the lost
chapters are my favorite so like it's
entirely possible that the new fable
could be something that i don't even
like but i
i want to see it really badly to see
what it is also demon souls
i'm pretty excited about that um those
are the ones that came to the top of my
head i'm sure if i looked at a list i'd
be like oh also this also this also this
but right now
my number one from a personal level from
like a
player level not from an industry level
is death loop casey matto said what's up
with the jadeness and cynicism of games
media industry
in regards to new consoles i can barely
contain my excitement for both and could
probably name 15 new games i'm excited
about
but the constant refrain is there's no
games why the hell would i want these uh
marketing can't fool me
uh et cetera um i have seen absolutely
no jadedness or cynicism from the game's
media industry so i don't know what
you're referring to
um why i shouldn't pay very much
attention to games media's truth
but my genuine answer to this is there
are a lot of people who work at these
companies and they have very different
opinions
um so there are probably a lot of people
who are really really really excited
and then other people who aren't uh
because it is kind of their jobs to cut
through the marketing hype to
to be more realistic um you are excited
because you have been marketed to be
excited these people have to try not to
be because
it is their jobs to just be as as
genuine to the facts as possible and
and there are absolutely a lot of cases
where people in games media are really
cynical to
the extent that i've always been like
man if i ever
get like that i shouldn't be working in
the industry if i always said if i ever
get to the point where i'm like oh i
hate e3 i don't want to do e3 then i
shouldn't be working in games and it's
so weird to be that some people even
stay
but that's still a well-rounded answer
while i don't doubt some of it exists
i've not seen any of it
at all um so i can't comment
part of it is people are jaded and
cynical uh that's
just people part of it is that they
aren't supposed to be as excited as you
because
it is their job as professionals to cut
through marketing
um but ultimately whenever someone comes
to me with
with questions about uh you know why is
the games media industry doing this
i i just want to say a a lot of
different people b if there's games
media who's saying stuff that you don't
like it doesn't actually
matter you know just find someone you
agree with
and follow them question from louise
smith here which like i don't want to
rule over because this is like a thing
that you know is serious but i don't
have a good answer to
um she said i'm from england living here
in the u.s and have not been home in six
years
i can't even imagine uh i'm struggling a
little with the thought of not being
able to travel for even longer and want
to know if you have any tips on how not
to feel
homesick or any fun things you do to
connect with family and friends um
no i mean i'm like the one thing that i
am is all about as someone who is
generally actually quite happy
yeah i'm missing my family sucks and i
don't have any advice for it other than
to like
i just kind of keep reminders of them in
my apartment like i have pictures up on
a wall and i have stuff that they've
sent me publicly displayed just sort of
like make my apartment feel a little bit
more like home
but the truth is i don't have any good
tips just a lot of phone calls
it's hard it's super hard neon bowser
said have you heard anything about that
and you can levine project why don't i
leave this as the last question this is
pretty long
i have seen ken levine's new game i went
to the studio
i saw the road map i know exactly what
it is and how it works
but i have no interest in leaking
anything to do with it uh that would do
nothing
but hurt ken levine and his project
and uh the stance i have on leaks is
that
there is no benefit to the public other
than
curiosity really and i think uh
it's a very cool thing that i think is
worth waiting to see
that's all i'm saying and on that note
everyone i'm alan i'll see you guys next
time
uh the link for the keep stuff will be
in the description
and yeah if you have any questions for
next month where in theory i will be
able to talk about
my new job you can leave them in the
comments section below
bye